just about one month left before
school's out and that means a lot of
families are already thinking about
summer vacation and hopefully trips that
won't break the bank with some great
ideas for traveling on a budget we are
joined by family fun expert don abazo
donna a lot of people happy now that uh
masks are no longer required on
airplanes but you're saying hey don't
throw the idea of a road trip out the
window yet i am i love the idea of a
road trip for a lot of reasons first of
all you're not tied to a schedule you
can hit the road anytime but i say the
family fun starts the minute you back
down the driveway hit that curve if
you're strategic so you know lots of
learning lots of games on the way there
and you're spending time together
um as soon as you hit the road road
trips are fun in that respect and to
your point no scheduling and you can
pack as much as you want you don't have
to worry about putting everything in one
little suitcase right right and they
save money too and what i like about
going on vacation is saving money i know
you have five kids i have three so i'm
always looking to save money so i can
maybe take another trip so my tip is to
think off season okay so this summer i
think families in vegas should think
scottsdale it's only yeah it's not too
far away too right it's only about five
hours depending on where you live and
when the temperatures soar the rates go
down believe me you can find so many
bargains and you can be strategic you
just work around the clock maybe it's
you hit golf early with the kids or you
do that hike through the desert when
it's early and then hit the polls they
have all kinds of fun pools they have
pool parties with dj's
massive water slides and then you know
evening's fun too lots of trendy dining
and all kinds of things so it really it
spans the the age realm you can take
your kids and enjoy it the adults will
enjoy it all sorts of activities
absolutely i've taken my three teens you
know through a hot uh horseback riding a
tour through the desert oh wow they love
that those pool parties i was talking
about you know not only do the kids get
excited but the teens get involved
they're a tricky bunch as you know you
mentioned road trips and that is where
it can be a lot of fun also sometimes a
little stressful with kids uh what are
some good things to do to help pass the
time or to bond along the way well i
love the idea of sort of a checklist or
treasure hunt so you can start talking
about things in the car on the way there
things you're going to see maybe it's
facts about the national forest if
you're going to scottsdale or facts
about cactus like you have one cactus
it's a cactus but what if you have
several right cacti right dye or
and i love for the ride home
take pictures maybe it's on the phone
maybe it's polaroids but get prints and
pack the kids with a little
scrapbook maybe one scrapbook or maybe
everyone has their own and you can they
can start building their vacation family
scrapbook on the way home and that kills
five hours right yeah yeah it's a way to
create you've written a couple of books
on fun right i have i have written two
books on fun what the fun and fidget
busters i love what the fun that's funny
i know it's another tricky name and
fidget busters is all about uh having
your kids
be busy with something if you have stuff
to do right absolutely a sensory plan
that's great for any
want any family with little ones are
looking to do that road trip there's
lots of little toys you can make or buy
that will keep them busy because it's a
little harder to talk them through all
those you know
facts we were talking about where can
people find your books and more
information well you can find my books
anywhere books are sold and you can
always follow me on instagram i'm at
donnabazzo all right donna thanks so
much for joining us today great tips
thank you happy summer everyone all
right